[Musique]
on va voir la deuxième partie de gilles
verdez et de pascal le grand frère
est ce que voulait voir la première
quand même au cas où oui on va regarder
la première
alors on va alors s'il vous plaît parce
que pour qu'on se remette en tête la
première c'est parti alors lui et gilles
verdez est un chroniqueur difficile mais
quand est ce que le conseil de classe de
ce bouffon il ne respecte rien ni
personne
jusqu'à présent personne n'a osé
affronter celui qui fait trembler les
plus grandes stars du paf
personne sauf lui qu'elle sautait plus
connu sous le nom et du grand frère
s'il vous plaît toujours c'est d'abord
qui vous envoie sa soeur après mais pour
quelle raison je sais pas et nietzsche
et inefficient et je mets en colère
regarde déjà on va commencer par ça rend
ma casquette lait sur la chaussée
apparemment tout le monde gueule
technique attention tout le monde suit
pas ce qu'est un couteau confrère le
petit fera plus tôt la chapelle du mont
joie c'est bien c'est bien l'école pour
l'instant merci à trouver somme supra
c'est en parler de tout ce qui te
dérange à la télévision et ailleurs
s'écouter tout dérange à la télé on te
dérange tant grand papa et moi l'intérêt
à quoi qu'il en soit n'est pas pour toi
moi et lui et lui par terre inconnue est
le temps qu il ait plus rien mais lui de
larmor alors tu viennes tapis gueule
maintenant photo tellement fait défaut c
est lui qui sait lui d'un super slogan
soyez beau c'est grand c'est beau gros
mois pour la première fois pascal a été
frappé au visage par un chroniqueur en
difficulté
comment va-t-il réagir la suite dans un
instant alors la fuite et bien ensuite
on va voir comment pascal a réagi s'est
bien passé avec lui très bien ouais bah
ça se voit à regarder
précédemment dans sos gilles verdez a
besoin des deux petits frères plutôt la
judée samarie callas je connais attends
je suis pas ton point que moi je te
parle correctement ces sujets complément
bertoua compris sujet verbe complément
car tu as raison oui mais voilà avec
l'amp est benjamin castaldi à dole a
géré la noue la anouar saad blog me
voilà gilles craque
pascal a enfin réussi à gagner sa
confiance se sont terminées par fait je
vois que de biens-fonds tu te sens tu as
changé ma vie franchement je te remercie
c'est génial franchement si tu déconnes
d'accord mais je suis plus un homme en
colère un seront fait calme et chercher
calmer merci pascal a pour gilles verdez
cette rencontre avec pascal a été une
révélation
merci pascal franchement c'est devenu
zen pas changer ma vie je suis un autre
homme
merci tout avait bien grosse fallait
tourner à gauche si c'est parce que t'as
qu'à gauche bouffon
[Applaudissements]